Oh young lady if you don't go sleep in
30 seconds it's gonna be bad news today
I'm going to learn how to become a dad
my wife and I are gonna have kids soon
but I'm completely terrified and
overwhelmed by that idea it seems like
it's a huge change in your life can you
still have a date night do you have to
find a babysitter every single time you
guys way harder than you think it's good
accepting that you're not going to be
super dad or perfect is part of being a
super dad you know I think often times
you want things skill in a way and they
don't always go that way she's back on
I'm gonna care for my friend Mike's kids
for a whole day
I'll see just how hard it is roll
yourself into it okay and don't be
afraid to do stuff guys want to take the
stairs or the elevator stairs stairs
taking the stairs was a difficult choice
oh I'm exhausted other thing that's
really hard is patience you've got to
have amazing patience when it comes to
kids guys like healthy snacks what about
this what about this can I have this
dance did you pick up something they're
gonna annoy you they're gonna take a
long time to do things like brushing
their teeth the breasts are tea for 20
minutes no no no we don't need ice cream
good zebra-print
heart pillow not getting boss today I
just wait see okay or should be he's
okay I got the eyes in the back of the
head watching that why are you hitting
my head it's love to play pretend one of
the things you get will take that back
one of the tough James Shh one more time
one of the tough things about playing
pretend with your kids is that it takes
a lot of mental like like concentration
it's right this whole castles made of
cookies and the Cookie Monster this is
this fun you guys we're just hanging out
oh boy Oh James James James okay it's
time to go to the ball Oh going to the
ball doing okay there James Oh is the
doors next to each other that is not
here anymore one of the tough things
about being a parent is special when
they're this age is making sure that
they eat healthy food if you eat
broccoli then I will give you the candy
do we have a deal oh no good to not make
a big show of it being weird
cherry cherry cherry interpreter
broccoli delivery for Captain James and
you've got to eat yourself because if
they see that you eat it then no one got
it
once you tip your hand that there's C a
and D Y somewhere you should probably
you know I should probably stop even
spelling out the word K no reals you
have like a safe word you know call like
asparagus would you rather have the
lollipop or the broccoli
classic putting your kids to bed that is
definitely difficult because kids don't
want it about bounce about can't bounce
too much how many stories do you
normally have before bed 600-million
night I love sleeping
I really am getting sleepy so they're
gonna fight you on it and they try to
stretch out that time routine as long as
it can possibly be ready for bed
okay bass drums are big but whistles are
little with that I said we're only doing
two ducks we're all doing two books
we're reading apparently as many books
as it takes I stirred it all together it
was yummy but it wasn't pink and that is
the end of Pinkalicious
that's how he's doing I was only with
the kids for a small period of time I
want to go into a hot bubble bath and
drink white why how did I do you know I
think you did actually really well you
were really engaged you're really
dedicated you were trying really hard
even though it was really difficult and
exhausting on my body
seeing the way Mike interacted with his
kids and how much they loved him and he
loved them that was it was just such a
nice feeling thumbs up or thumbs down
how do you think I did yeah so we've got
some work to do I think of all the
things that my dad did for me and I'm so
thankful so what do you think do you
think you ready to possibly in the near
future take the leap and then call my
wife how's it going I've been shooting
the video I'm taking care of a toddler I
hope so yeah it seems seems really hard
oh we have like babies guy I love me too
she said let's make babies which is
pretty awesome as well as terrifying